make no mistake phil traded us and
wasn't supposed to trade us joe
we'd have been cool over there new york
joe like we still would have wore some
[ __ ] after a while we just wasn't
together long enough right
broke us up phil i don't know what you
was doing phil but that was incorrect
yeah um jackson kind of [ __ ] the
knicks up for a few years yeah shout out
to you for that bro
um
but uh
when we got over there like it took us
it took us just a quick second to like
be able to really like go to war with
each other and practice i feel like
right
when we first got over there we were
still banged up i was still coming off a
shoulder injury
i dislocated my shoulder i hadn't been
playing so when we got traded uh
just jr was playing but he was like
nursing something as well like we were
just coming over everything was just
sort of random i don't think he like did
much his first game
and then um
once we got into
incident practices
we had some special practices that team
like
uh
i don't know like before we got when we
first showed up like before i started
practicing i just remember coming in
practice and being like bro this is too
smooth like
y'all have no beef like there's no
hectic there's nothing like there's
nothing to push y'all at all
and um
that's what me
j.r and mazzy that's what we was like
that's what we own there because y'all
got
kyrie katie i mean uh lebron
kay love and brian so it's like
it ain't like it's gonna be many
basketballs being passed around you know
what i'm saying too crazy um so
we just sort of brought like a toughness
and a swag and a fun you know what i'm
saying like i feel like damn near they
was scared to celebrate a 3.0 you know
what i'm saying like if you watch them
they was just like regular like yeah
yeah good job yeah it was just like
great guys like yeah all good good play
like
and then when we got there we was just
like yeah we don't do we got some swag
yeah we just uh like yeah we coming from
new york we just
you know what i'm saying like we're used
to giving that showman like our crowd
like that [ __ ] right we like we we point
at the crowd and start talking [ __ ] new
york love that [ __ ] i'm like y'all just
gonna have to get with it over here i
don't know what y'all got going on but
we not doing this quietly like that's
what we brought to the team but it was
like marching through that and seeing
brian
um like once we lost kai and he hacked
his knee
um
because quiet is kept bro when that
missed shot came off in game one if i
throw that mod back in it's a different
series because cod never halves his knee
you know what i'm saying like kyrie
plays that seriously that went into
overtime no he did play that series no
i'm saying if but if he plays that full
series oh that's what i'm saying if he
plays the full series i think you guys
win if i hit that and then basketball is
different forever
because y'all wouldn't be running around
shooting all these threes my man
wouldn't be over here shaking his head
all confidently with this golden state
[ __ ] k.d probably come over there and
play with us as opposed to them because
we won
you know what i'm saying
see what he did
you see what i did man
katie would have been like day one over
there we figured out for to go over here
shake with them me and brian from the
play together y'all finna be mad
that would but that would have ruined
basketball too so i can't either way it
ruined basketball
no he didn't it wasn't katie it was
braun first going to miami